bevor wir loslegen muss ich erstmal was
loswerden
eingeständnis also wir haben uns diesmal
echt schwer getan mit der entscheidung
zu diesem inside politik sollen wir euch
dieses schwere thema wirklich liefern
würden wir als hauptstadtkorrespondenten
damit nicht hineingezogen in einen
unkontrollierbaren konflikt müssten wir
nicht jeden schritt abstimmen mit
anderen medien aber dann haben wir
gesagt komm schluss mit dem zaudern
jetzt wird geliefert und damit 8
endete ironie vielleicht ist es euch
aufgefallen ganz ähnlich wie eben
argumentiert olaf scholz wenn es um die
lieferung von waffen an die ukraine geht
ist er also ein zauderer der den
ukrainern nicht genug hilft oder hat
scholz recht weil er tut was er kann und
dabei das risiko für deutschland klein
das business ukrainian verbreitet auf
twitter zu holzen stehe in der ukraine
nun für wenn man etwas zuständig
verspreche aber nicht die absicht habe
es einzuhalten olaf scholz wird dagegen
ein ganz anderes image das er führen
kann dass er zeigt wo es lang geht hier
das ist auch 2011 als erster
bürgermeister von hamburg wurde wenn
alle sagen sie möchten dass sich die
führung der hamburger spd übernehme dann
bekommen alle das was sie bestellt haben
mich erinnert das an ein gespräch mit
ihm im januar 2009 10 im ritz carlton in
peking scholz war damals finanzminister
hatte den ganzen tag im feinen zwirn mit
chinesen riesigen hallen konferiert und
sich dafür eingesetzt dass deutsche bank
in china bessere geschäfte machen können
später haben wir dann in jeans und
verwaschenem t shirt zu einem dieser
hintergrundgesprächen die spd stand
damals bei 15 prozent die union bei fast
doppelt so viel und die spd vorsitzende
andrea nahles scholz erklärt uns damals
rund heraus dass das unter seiner
führung anders wäre man müsse halt auch
bei gegenfeuer ruhig bleiben er selbst
war in peking übrigens nicht ganz so
ruhig und mutig für chinesische
menschenrechtler hatte bei seinem besuch
keine zeit hätte shipping co vielleicht
geärgert was ich damit meine es gibt
diese kluft zwischen wuchtigen worten
und seinem anderen damals in peking und
jetzt auch womit wir bei seiner
berühmten zeitenwende rede sind drei
tage nach dem angriff russlands auf die
ukraine damals schon steht er mächtig
unter druck weil scholz erstmals oder
bei waffenlieferungen bei sanktionen und
dann kommt das wir erleben eine
zeitenwende
das ziel ist eine leistungsfähige
hochmoderne fortschrittliche bundeswehr
der bundeshaushalt
2022 wird dieses sondervermögen einmalig
mit 100 milliarden euro ausstatten 100
milliarden für die bundeswehr und schutz
der ukraine das waren die beiden
zentralen versprechen dieser rede was
ist eigentlich daraus geworden
sondervermögen bundeswehr kann man sagen
haben bundestag und bundesrat
beschlossen kommt aber schutz der
ukraine waffenlieferungen ja es gibt
einen beschluss des bundestages zur
lieferung schwerer waffen also allem was
mehr ist als nur panzerfäusten
handgranaten und munition und es gibt
wieder ein paar wuchtige worte von olaf
scholz niemand lieferten ähnlich großem
umfang deutschland das tut niemand
liefert so viel wie deutschland stimmt
das denn am institut für weltwirtschaft
in kiel haben wissenschaftler ein uk
support trecker eingerichtet dass uns
mal nachschauen wo deutschland dasteht
in absoluten zahlen steht deutschland
unter den top fünf hinter den usa
großbritannien und polen ganz anders
aber sieht es aus wenn man die
militärische unterstützung ins
verhältnis setzt zur wirtschaftskraft
dann rutscht deutschland weit nach unten
noch hinter luxemburg tschechien und
denner und die wuchtigen worte von olaf
scholz niemand lieferten ähnlich großem
umfang wie deutschland es tut passen mal
wieder nicht recht zu seinem handeln
hier noch mal eine kleine inside
geschichte für euch wir konnten vor
kurzem exklusiv bei einem
rüstungsunternehmen drehen sonst kommst
du da nicht rein hier sind unsere bilder
bei der ffg in flensburg steht viel von
dem was die ukraine im krieg gegen
russland gerne hätte eingeparkt rund 100
leopard 1 kampfpanzer außerdem 60 panzer
mauser m 113 sowie brücken und
pionierpanzer von der bundeswehr
ausgemustert aber noch ganz gut
verwendbar die ffg bietet seit märz an
diese waffen in die ukraine zu liefern
aber berlin zögert man soll sich nicht
in die irre leiten lassen von der
rüstungsindustrie die witwe hat jetzt
die chance ihre alten sachen zu
vertreten erklärt scholz aber die
ukraine sagt sie hätten die sachen kann
warum also geben wie sie nicht einfach
darauf sagt scholz kein anderes
westliches land würde moderne
kampfpanzer liefern alles abgestimmt mit
den verbündeten von wegen zaudern grund
sind die männer parlamentarische
staatssekretär im
verteidigungsministerium behauptet bei
uns in berlin direkt sogar es gebe eine
nato absprache dazu ich möchte dazu zwei
dinge festhalten erst mal haben wir
gemeinsam im nato bündnis mit allen
westlichen nationen festgehalten die
entscheidung wird auch gemeinschaftlich
getragen dass keine schützen oder
kampfpanzer westlichen modells geliefert
werden und dazu gibt es auch bisher
keine veränderung der position einer
westlichen nationen echt jetzt eine
entscheidung der nato quasi ein
offizieller beschluss in der
bundespressekonferenz muss ein sprecher
des
verteidigungsministeriums kurz darauf
zurück rudern da ist der wortlaut
wesentlich von einer entscheidung war
nicht die rede ich meine aber ich hätte
bei frau müller das wort entscheidung
gehört oder die entscheidung wird auch
gemeinschaftlich getragen aha und
natürlich der westen liefert kampfpanzer
tschechien und polen die 72 das sind
panzer sowjetischer bauart da hat scholz
nichts dagegen aber dass die leopard 1
die in flensburg stehen und ungefähr
genauso alt wie die t 72 sind dass die
in die ukraine kommen das will ich holz
nicht t-72 sind okay bei leopard 1 droht
aber dass deutschland in den krieg
hineingezogen wird soll das die rote
linie sein da verstehe ich olaf scholz
argumentation nicht kannst oder seht ihr
das anders völlig verwirrend wird es
jetzt deutschland hat inzwischen
zugesagt den flug abwehrpatzer gepaart
aus dem panzer haubitzen und
raketenwerfer zu liefern ja das sind
vielleicht rein technisch keine schützen
oder kampfpanzer aber ziemlich nah dran
das geht das andere partout nicht es
wirkt wie soll man sagen schaudernd okay
und jetzt überspringen wir mal den fast
forward all die anderen zauber rissmann
von scholz seine wortklauberei mit der
er vor dem krieg nord stream zwei nicht
in den mund nehmen will und jetzt nicht
sagen will dass die ukraine diesen krieg
besser gewinnen sollte oder die tatsache
dass bei das halbe kabinett nach kiew
gereist ist nur olaf scholz nicht warum
macht er das ist das ein zaudern nach
der methode scholz vielleicht sogar ein
doppeltes spiel wie die union ihm
vorwirft in einer sitzung des
koalitionsausschusses ende april
verteidigte scholz mal seinen kurs so
ich bin nicht kaiservilla soll ja gesagt
hatten also damit meint er will ich dass
deutschland wie im ersten weltkrieg
unter wilhelm dem zweiten quasi aus
versehen in einen krieg rutsche der
britische historiker christopher clark
hat ein buch darüber geschrieben und die
großen mächte als schlafwandler
bezeichnete die gefahr eines weltkrieges
nicht sehen wollten oder konnten das
also ist scholz große sorge aber klar
selbst sagt es sie kaum analogien zur
lage heute eher im gegenteil zieht
scholz also am ende die falschen
historischer schlüssel oder ist eine art
von grund bockigkeit bei ihm da dass er
das was alle von den fordern schon mal
erst recht nicht macht ich glaube dass
es sich mit der zeitenwende ein bisschen
so verhält wie mit der geschichte aus
peking die ich euch vorher zeit habe die
worte sind wichtig aber das handeln ist
es nicht den vollständigen bruch den
putin mit seinem anschluss krieg
verzogen hat den will scholz selbst nur
höchst ungern nachvollziehen er laviert
er zaudert als wollte er sich doch
irgendwie noch ein türchen offen halten
wie seht ihr das zaubert nicht und
schreibt uns wir sind gespannt auf eure
meinungen